Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans ScienceClic,
nous allons tenter de comprendre les mécanismes
mathématiques de la relativité générale.
Pour ce faire, nous allons construire petit
à petit tous les outils mathématiques essentiels
à la relativité générale.
Pour éviter de surcharger le contenu, cette
série sera découpée en plusieurs parties,
dans lesquelles nous allons façonner chaque
notion une à une, et qui seront publiées
dans des vidéos indépendantes.
Les calculs et équations seront montrés,
en espérant que le tout reste abordable,
et intuitif.
Chaque vidéo commencera par une explication
théorique, suivie d’un ou plusieurs exemples
concrets, pour mettre en application les concepts
développés.
Dans cette série, nous allons réinventer
chaque concept de A à Z, et pour commencer
il est donc important de tout oublier, de
faire table rase sur toutes les notions que
l’on pense connaître, de partir de rien.
Devant nous, une feuille de papier, sur laquelle
est tracée une courbe.
Cette feuille de papier est une image pour
représenter la structure de notre univers,
l’espace-temps.
Celui-ci possède 4 dimensions, mais dans
cette image simplifiée, on ne représentera
que deux de ces dimensions.
La courbe, à la surface de la feuille décrit
un objet, par exemple, une pomme.
Cette courbe est ce qu'on appelle sa ligne
d'univers.
Nous allons tenter d’interpréter cette
courbe.
Pour commencer, on découpe la ligne d’univers
en de petits intervalles réguliers.
A partir d’un point quelconque que l’on
choisit, on numérote ces intervalles un à
un.
De cette façon, on munit la courbe d’une
graduation, qui nous permet de la transformer
en une série de points consécutifs.
Ces points seront interprétés comme une
trajectoire.
La courbe n’est plus un objet, mais un mouvement,
elle représente le mouvement de la pomme
dans l’espace-temps.
On vient d’inventer la notion de déplacement.
On appellera ces graduations au cours desquelles
se déplace la pomme son temps propre.
Le temps propre de la pomme correspond au
temps qui rythme son évolution interne, en
quelque sorte, c’est le temps qui s’écoulerait
sur sa propre horloge.
Tandis qu’il augmente, la pomme évolue,
et se déplace à travers les dimensions de
l’espace-temps.
Dans la suite, le temps propre sera désigné
par la lettre grecque tau.
Maintenant que la pomme se déplace sur la
feuille, on désire décrire sa position,
au fil du temps propre.
Pour pouvoir repérer un point de façon mathématique,
on va munir notre feuille d’un système
de coordonnées.
Un tel système se présente comme une grille
que l’on trace sur la feuille.
Cette grille possède une origine, un point
zéro, à partir duquel on compte les cases
une par une.
De cette façon, la position de la pomme sur
la feuille va être décrite par deux nombres,
qu’on appelle ses coordonnées.
Il est important de comprendre que cette grille
est arbitraire.
Elle n’a pas de sens physique, il s’agit
simplement d’une convention que l’on choisit,
un support abstrait dont l’utilité est
de décrire les points par des nombres.
En fonction de la situation que l’on analyse,
certains systèmes de coordonnées seront
plus appropriés que d’autres, et nous aurons
la liberté d’utiliser celui qui nous satisfait.
Illustrons tous ces concepts, par un exemple
concret.
Imaginons une pomme qui tombe verticalement
à la surface de la Terre, et que nous observons
depuis une très grande distance.
En tant qu’observateurs distants, intéressons-nous
aux quantités que l’on peut mesurer.
D’une part, on peut mesurer la distance
qui sépare la pomme du centre de la Terre.
Comme la chute de la pomme se fait verticalement,
cette unique distance permet de repérer la
position de la pomme, sans ambiguïté.
D’autre part, on peut mesurer le temps,
par rapport à notre horloge, qui ne va pas
forcément s’écouler de la même façon
que le temps propre de la pomme.
De cette façon, on peut définir deux coordonnées,
qu’on appellera t pour le temps, et r pour
l’altitude, qui permettent de positionner
la pomme dans l’espace-temps de façon relative
à notre point de vue.
Alors que son temps propre s’écoule, la
pomme va pouvoir se déplacer librement, et
tracer sa trajectoire à l’intérieur de
ce système de coordonnées.
Attention, il est important de bien distinguer
le temps t, qui est une coordonnée, et le
temps propre tau, qui représente quant à
lui la graduation sur la ligne d’univers.
Pour bien comprendre nos deux coordonnées,
prenons un exemple.
Si la pomme passe par le point dont les coordonnées
sont 1 seconde, et 7000 km, cela signifie
que lorsque notre horloge indique 1 seconde,
on mesurera une distance de 7000 km, entre
la pomme et le centre de la Terre.
Dans l’espace-temps, il est important de
comprendre qu’aucun objet n’est immobile.
En effet, même s’il ne se déplace pas
dans l’espace, comme une pomme qui resterait
immobile sur Terre, un corps va quand même
se déplacer dans le temps, la pomme avance
chaque seconde vers notre futur.
Les objets ont donc tous une vitesse dans
l’espace-temps, et c’est uniquement la
répartition de cette vitesse entre les différentes
coordonnées d’espace, et de temps, qui
va pouvoir varier.